et pour en parler nous sommes avec nadia
rayman la présidente de la brigade des
mers bonsoir madame à rayman la mairie
ou comment vous avez jugé ce discours d'
emmanuel macron s'attendait pas
franchement à des annonces il a déjà
commencé en faire sur ce plan ça vous
semble s'annoncer pas mal il prend la
bonne voie pour vous ou non on est en
moi bon effectivement alors vous
connaissez mon combat et tout ça ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on attend que
justement juste de notre président se
manifestent justement alors moi j'ai
ramené de courrier alors on a écrit un
courrier on peut le pr le 15 juin 2018
on alerte monsieur notre manuel da cruz
un autre courrier le de ces juillet 2010
est effectivement où il fait part de la
situation dans les quartiers où tout ça
où on a une réponse en me disant bravo
pour le travail que vous faites mais on
n'a aucun retour
alors aujourd'hui monsieur vaincrons je
pense qu'il voyait s'il est dans son
rôle quand il est dans la communication
s'est fait ici faire et ses communiqués
alors j'ai entendu effectivement un
moment donné par les de réconquérir les
quartiers alors avec conquérir ça veut
dire se trouve le mot un peu mignon et
conquérir c'est reprendre les quartiers
de toute façon ça veut dire qu'on les a
perdus les quartiers il parle d'échec
clairement d'un des chefs de
communautarisme je pense que lui il a
commencé justement son mandat avec ça il
faut pas oublier qu'il a mis dans la
tête de liste pour les villes de
quartier nous amie annie morris
quelqu'un qui n'avait rien à voir avec
les quartiers qu'ils n'avaient aucune
expérience de terrain
c'est son copain jeter mais là tu gères
les quartiers la preuve la personne a
démissionné et moi j'avais rencontré
monsieur président avant qu'ils soient
présents sept ou huit mois je lui avais
fait effectivement une analyse de
terrain notre inquiétude est tous à ce
qui se passe dans le quartier
j'avais l'impression d'avoir en face de
moi quelqu'un je parlais d'un autre pays
et pas de la france est aujourd'hui
justement va revenir sur les mesures que
j'ai regardé avec mon équipe on a étudié
tout ça j'espère que ce n'est pas que de
la com parce que je pense qu'il faut
prendre un moment donné faut être
sérieux dans notre pays et ce qui me
fait peur c'est que quand il va il va
travailler encore les mains avec les
mêmes associations pour certains aspects
de son curé ya des associations qui font
un travail formidable dans les quartiers
si il va toujours travaillé avec les
mêmes en fin de compte on est on
s'échange les associations on va genre
fermer une ou deux associations
mais on va laisser des associations qui
est justement qu'on dénonce depuis
plusieurs années je pense qu'il va pas
prendre vraiment les grandes décisions
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les français
c'est ce qu'ils ont besoin
on n'en peut plus de vivre dans ces
quartiers où effectivement et à cette
politique je le répète tout le temps
mais pas assez la politique des grands
frères je pense qu'il faut pas oublier
un truc important macron vient de chez
monsieur hollande
il connaissait les quartiers c'est pas
quelque chose qui découvre alors
l'impression qu'ils découvrent les
quartiers qui découvre aujourd'hui faut
tirer le signal d'alarmé
l'appellation séparatisme islamistes on
a beaucoup parlé de ces mots qui ont
leur importance de la l'elysée beaucoup
tergiversé sur voilà est-ce qu'on parle
de communautarisme de radicalisation ou
vos larmes de séparatisme islamique ça
vous semble être bien choisi ce terme on
nomme les choses on un peu pourquoi pas
mais dans un sens il nous parle de
séparatistes islamistes et dans un sens
il nous a pompé ya pas longtemps encore
l'islam de france et il travaille pour
l'islam de france
alors effectivement non c'est
contradictoire pour moi c'est
contradictoire
on ne peut pas parler d'islam de france
c'est comme si on parlait de
christianisme de france etc
alors aujourd'hui il parle de ses parts
à 10 mais on sait qu'à côté ya d'autres
projets justement sur l'islam de france
on continue à former les imams on retire
les postes d'éducateurs de médiateur
leva la police etc
alors je pense et j'espère me tromper un
je pense que c'est encore de la
communication est allé municipal qui
arrive on est allé présidentielle mine
de rien dans trois ans je pense je pense
que les mots qu'on croit monsieur le
président effectivement peuvent paraître
pour certains effectivement on va se
dire enfin
mais pour nous qui sommes dans les
quartiers on va dire de toute façon il
faudra vraiment que cette fois ci tient
ses promesses parce que je pense qu'on
va l'attendre au tournant
particulièrement nous lesquelles les
gens qui travaillent en soit dans les
quartiers on peut plus me laisser tomber
alors aller
dans le détail de ces mesures l'une
d'entre elles notamment emmanuel macron
qui a annoncé qu'il souhaitait arrêter
le système des imams détachées pour
former des imams directement sur le sol
français est écouté aujourd'hui on a je
le disais 300 imams détachées qui sont
envoyées en france chaque année
et donc ce qu'ils sont et 20 en 2020
seront la dernière génération avec ce
volume et nous allons progressivement
sortir c'est à dire ne peut en faire
venir de nouveaux et laisser la période
de présence des dernier imam détachées
se poursuivre jusqu'à son terme avec là
aussi un dialogue une amélioration des
conditions
en parallèle de sa ce que nous devons
faire est ce que nous allons faire c'est
y revenir dans un instant former des
imams en france pour qu'ils puissent
maîtriser la langue et les lois de la
république
donc nous allons ainsi progressivement
mettre fin au système des imams
détachées et là aussi de manière
progressive
opsahl mots durs qui sont accueillis
spécifiquement chaque année à l'occasion
du ramadan
il y en a environ 300 cette sortie de ce
qu'on appelle l'islam consulaire est
elle aussi extrêmement importante pour
pouvoir réduire ses influences
étrangères
et là aussi permettre de s'assurer que
chacune et chacun respecte pleinement
les lois de la république dans un cadre
qui est connu de tous les diables n'a
j'envoyais sourire ces annonces vont
quand même pas dans le bon sens pour
vous réduit recension c'est ce que les
imams les plus rigoureux qu'on a ce sont
des jeunes qui sont nés en france et des
français justement si on prend par
exemple l'exemple de tariq oubrou et
plein d'autres justement se sont saisis
même là justement qui sont sur le
terrain depuis des années qu'ils sont
déjà formés justement en france qui vont
être nommés j'aimerais bien qu'ils nous
donnent les noms de ces mêmes qui ne qui
vont parvenir de l'étranger mais qui
sont sur les arts sur le territoire
français et qui sont de nationalité
française
je prends toujours par exemple on a le
l'imam de drancy et haricots broue
compagnie je pense qu'il a fait
justement son son tri et ça sera
toujours la même histoire
le problème c'est pas former les imams
et encore une fois c'est pas les formes
et on n'a pas besoin de former les imams
ce que dans l'islam sont la plaque large
et ça nous regarde pas les imams les
fidèles c'est à eux de choisir leurs
emails c'est pas à la république de se
mêler c'est là le séparatisme l'état
doit rester neutre doit avoir bien sûr
on doit observer mais c'est pas à la
france de de former des imams encore
mouahahaha notre république la pierre
jetée dans le jardin de la turquie de
l'algérie ça vous semblait effectivement
pour le jeu comprend effectivement là on
dans un sens il nous parle de la
colonisation il nous fait des joueurs
comme quoi qu'on est telle que les
français c'était les méchants et
aujourd'hui dit bon il faut faire
attention la lire et la turquie à tout
mais moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on parle
de la responsabilité de la france
les jeunes qui sont partis en syrie sont
des jeunes français ils sont pas venus
d'algérie ou de turquie ce sont des
français qui sont partis et si on
revient sur l'histoire des imams je vous
dis on n'a pas à former les imams en
forme des éducateurs des médiateurs des
policiers des enseignants et ne l'ont
sait qu'il n'ya pas de problème
justement avec les imams et celle ci
c'est quand même une partie mais il ya
des problèmes parce que pourquoi parce
que l'état s'en est mêlé parce que les
musulmans toujours vécu en france depuis
qu'ils sont devenus politisé comme tariq
oubrou je pourrais en citer d'autres
c'est depuis que la politique s'en est
mêlée depuis qu'on a fait les fameux
iftar républicain et j'en passe et
l'islam de france qu'elle les problèmes
on leur a ouvert la porte on l'a rouvert
le porte la porte de l'elysée
la porte des préfectures moi j'ai vu des
imams dans la préfecture dans seine
saint denis
on avait l'impression que c'était eux
c'étaient des enseignants elle avait
impliqué des éducateurs on a quand même
fait appel aux imams quant à eux les
émeutes de banlieue en fin de compte on
leur a donné un rôle plus important
qu'il le devait a ni même il doit faire
appel à la prière c'est comme un traître
ou un rabbin et tout ça c'est pour ça
que le militant pro ils ont été
sélectionné c'est ce que vous nous dites
du nizoral sélectionner les gars on a
fait ils ont fait la même chose en
algérie on a essayé de former les imams
en algérie on veut dire c'est un pays
musulman à la base on peut comprendre
mais en france on a en plus je vais vous
demander comment c'est la formation des
imams
la formation des imams c'est un document
qu'on vous donne vous parle des valeurs
de la république mais à l'imam il est
avant tout religieux
il va d'abord faire ce qu'il va lire
d'abord le coran avant de venir la chair
qu'on va lui donner mais se battront
quelqu'un d'autre alors formé me et en
plus il faut faire les formateurs moi
j'ai vu les gens qui forment les images
ils sont toujours dans dans la religion
on et on les forme pas ils ont pas un
truc où c'est la république et tout ça
c'est qu'on dit la formation des imams
je voudrais savoir qu'on nous donne le
document c'est quoi le programme de la
formation la formation de ckoi c'est ce
que tu as le droit de dire ce que tu
manges
mais l'imam caine dans la série la
mosquée il est libre et disent qu'ils
veulent puisque c'est lui qui fait les
prêches et tout le monde est libre de
d'écouter cet imam coups de badine
alors moi la formation des images des
plutôt surveiller et inspectés comme on
inspecte à l'éducation nationale un
enseignant en eps a inspecté les mêmes
il faut arrêtez arrêtez avec l'islam de
france
il faut effectivement nous sommes tous
républicains nous avons tous les mêmes
droits on peut pas dire d'un côté on
veut former l'islam et d'un côté servait
séparatisme et d'un côté vouloir former
les imams ça veut dire moi je pense que
c'est contradictoire après peut-être que
je me trompe mais moi je pense qu'on
attend comme tout le monde comme tous
les français
merci beaucoup en tout cas mal hier et
maintenant d'avoir été avec nous nous
avoir apporté votre analyse après le
discours d' emmanuel macron à mulhouse
merci à vous aussi